il y à des villages où on fait des
concours pour savoir qui a la plus belle
boîte à lettres ou le jardin le plus
fleuri à luri c'est différent les
habitants rivalisent d'inventivité pour
s'opposer au projet de plateforme
logistique qui risque d'augmenter
considérablement à trafic routier déjà
très dense duré pratiquement plus de 800
camions qui passeraient sur l'itinéraire
là et se ferait à baup et plus de dix
mille véhicules qui seraient cruciales
sur l'ut 1h
si elle voit le jour cette plateforme
qui provoquerait également la
destruction de 40 hectares de forêt
serait avec eu 160 mille mètres carrés
de superficie
l'une des plus grandes de france son
promoteur le groupe argan prévoit d'y
implanter 700 emplois un argument auquel
sont sensibles habituellement les élus
locaux
et pourtant les maires des communes
voisines sont tous opposés au projet
dont je connais la situation du chômage
et au donc des gens seraient peut-être
content de trouver du travail mais à un
moment donné la balance elle est du
mauvais côté passé est trop de voilà
trop de camions s'est on peut pas sous
prétexte qu'il y aura de l'emploi ou des
retombées on ne peut pas se gâcher la
vie quotidienne pour ça aucune
collectivité locale est associé au
projet né d'un accord entre le groupe
argan est le propriétaire du terrain la
société lexmark qui a fermé son usine il
ya quelques années
l'agglo d'orléans aimerait bien en être
partenaire à condition qu'il soit
modifié
non on a des terrains peut-être près de
l'autoroute a déniché à trouver et
et encore quand je reprends l'autoroute
10 6 jusqu à sarran il ya quand même des
terrains disponibles sur le côté et qui
gênerait personne et qui gênerait
personne mais d'un autre côté on aurait
quand même 700 à 800 emplois
le dossier est maintenant dans les mains
du préfet qui d'ici fin août doit donner
son feu vert ou pas à la construction
d'ici là les riverains vont chercher à
se faire entendre en essayant de faire
plus de bruit que les camions